I'm still so nervous apparently if you
can blow it out no I'm still really
nervous but touch my boob oh that's
worked um thank you so much glamour I
know it's working now I'm serious
shall I stop okay sorry and thank you so
much I mean it Joe for supporting me for
such a long time it's been quite a while
and I quite confused as to why I'm still
here and doing my favorite thing in the
world I feel so lucky every day and I
think it's down to people like you
supporting me cuz I feel like I'm a real
woman and you've had me on the cover and
that's amazing so thank you for
supporting real women and also because I
genuinely am surrounded by the coolest
women the coolest people in my life I
think that's the most important thing to
me always surround yourself with the
best people and also my boyfriend I got
to bring who I think might be the
coolest first and ever
punching above my weight so but honestly
thank you so much I just feel so lucky I
get to do what I love and I get to hang
around with amazing people so thank you
thank you so much
[Music]